[Music]
you're fixing men part-time gangsters
you don't break the law he knows
we just pinned it
make peace
for everybody
i'm so familiar with
what you do
your father invented it
i understand your influence within the
prisons is
unique
[Music]
the answer is inside those walls not
outside
if you want to know who's running what
anytime where
come to me
what you see is what you get
i don't take sides
why did you pick up a ship ma don't
start your brothers are involved i'm
sure what aren't they involved in
he's gonna have to keep his mouth shut
and he's gonna have to do what he's told
the food chain here
there's a lot of wolves and only a few
rabbits
why does he call him the mayor
because he runs the city i wonder what
the real mayor thinks of that
the real mayor knows it too just do what
you got to do on that
in this home must be dead
if it wasn't for you
[Applause]
[Music]
if this is gonna work for anyone
everyone has to trust us
[Music]
anything i'll ever give you
i could take away an afternoon
don't ever threaten me again
[Music]
you